you have advice for young people
in high school
you're giving a lot of people look up to
you for advice for strength
for um strength to
search for themselves to find themselves
take on some responsibility
do something for other people
you're doing something for yourself
while you're doing that even if you
don't know it
for sure because you're a community
across time
find something to serve
somebody to help someone to help us a
job to find a job do your best with the
customers don't be above your job you're
going to get an entry level job when
you're a kid or what else
would you want you want to be the boss
what do you know you don't know anything
you could be the boss of your job
you know if you're working in a grocery
store or you're working in a convenience
store assuming you're not working for
terrified tyrants
you can be nice to the customers you can
develop your social skills you can learn
how to handle boss employee relationship
you can be there 15 minutes early and
leave 15 minutes late like you can learn
in an entry-level job man and i'll tell
you if you take an entry-level job and
you learn and it's a reasonably decent
place you will not be in an entry-level
job for long because everyone who's
competent is desperate for competent
people and if you go and show yourself
as competent there'll be a trial period
but if you go show yourself as competent
all sorts of doors you didn't even know
were there will start opening like mad
so you strive for competence
for craftsmanship yeah yeah yeah for
discipline
you know i mean
i i said in one of the chapters in my
books is is focused on putting your
house in order it's like well how do you
start
make your bed
you know i i it actually took me quite a
long time in my life before i made my
bed regularly in the morning most of my
life was put in pretty good order but
that was one thing i didn't have in
order
my clothes in my closet as well all
that's in order not all of it i'm
cleaning out some drawers right now but
look around and see what bugs you in
your room just look it's like okay i'm
in my room do i like this room no it
bugs me okay
why well the paint's peeling there and
it's dusty there and the carpet's dirty
and that corner is kind of ugly and the
light there isn't very good and my
clothes closet's a mess so i don't even
like to open it um okay that's a lot of
problems
that sucks that's a lot of opportunity
pick something and fix it
something that bugs you
yeah but not too much so the rule is
pick something you know would make pick
a problem
pick a solution to it that you know
would help
that you could do
that you would do
so you have to negotiate with yourself
it's like well i won't clean up this
room how do you know i've been in here
for 10 years and i've never cleaned it
up it's like well obviously that's too
big a dragon for you would you clean one
drawer
find out
and so imagine now you want to be happy
when you open that drawer and you think
well that's stupid it's like is it
maybe it's your sock drawer which i
cleaned up in my room the other day by
the way you're gonna you're gonna open
that every morning
so that's like 30 seconds of your life
every day
okay so that's
three minutes a
week that's 12 minutes a
month that's two hours a year
so maybe your life is made out if you've
got 16 hours a day let's figure this out
5 12 in an hour 12 in an hour
144 in 12 hours yeah let's say 200. 205
minute chunks that's your life ladies
and gentlemen jordan peterson did just
some math how many five-minute chunks
there are in a day and i got pretty sure
that's pretty accurate it's
approximately right so
you got 200 5-minute chunks and they
repeat a lot of them repeat
so if you get every one of those right
they're trivial right who cares what my
sock drawer looks like it's like fair
enough man but that's your life the
things you repeat every day
the mundane things think i could get all
those mundane things right
that's the game rules it's like now the
mundane is in place
now you can play because all the
mundane's in place and this is actually
true so with children
imagine you want your children to play
well play is very fragile neurologically
any competing motivation or emotion will
suppress play
so everything has to be in order
everything has to be a walled garden
before the children will play
that's a good way of thinking about it
so you put everything in order and you
think oh my god now i'm tyrannized by
this order it's like no you aren't not
if it's voluntary
and then the order is the precondition
for the freedom
and so then all of a sudden you get all
these things in order it's like oh look
at this i've got some room to play here
and then
then maybe you're not depressed now it's
it's often not that simple you know it's
not that simple try putting your room in
order perfect order that's hard i mean
it's a really powerful way to think
about those five-minute chunks just get
one of them right in a day
yeah if you do that for 200 days
your life is in order yeah
you know i thought i did that with my
clients a lot so a lot of them would
come home from work the guys say and and
their wife would meet them at the door
and it'd be a fight right away
you know and it's a clash there because
he comes home and he's tired hungry he's
worked all day and he's hoping that you
know he gets welcomed when he comes back
to the home but then the wife is at home
and she's been with the kids all day and
she's tired and hungry and she's hoping
that when he comes home he'll show her
some appreciation for what's happened
today and then they clash and then they
both have problems to discuss because
they've had their troubles during the
day and so then every time they get
together
they're not like it's a bit of a fight
for 20 minutes and then the whole
evening is screwed
and so then you think okay
here's the
deal it's knock and the door will open
okay you get to pick
how what happens when you come home
but you have to figure out what it is so
now this is the deal
you treat yourself properly
you imagine coming home and it goes the
way you want and need it to go
okay
what does that look like
you get to have it but you have to know
what it is
what does it look like
and you think okay i want to come home i
want to be happy about coming home i
come home
i open the door i say hello honey i'm
home
my wife says hi it's so nice to hear
your voice she comes up she says
hi dear she gives you a hug she says how
was your day and you say well we'll sit
and talk about that how was your day
well we'll sit and talk about that do
you need something to eat
probably
let's go sit and talk about our day it's
like that sounds pretty good okay that
sounds pretty good might not be perfect
sounds a hell of a lot better than what
we're doing now so how about we go
talk to
we'll go talk to your wife and say okay
this is what's happening when i come
home i would like it to be better
what would you like to have happen
if you could have what you wanted and so
she sits down and she thinks okay if he
comes home what do i want to have happen
and then now you've got two visions and
you say well what would you like and
you listen and she says
what would you like can you tell her and
then you think okay now can we bring
these visions together
so not only do we both get what we want
but because we've brought them together
we even get more than we want well who
wouldn't agree to that unless they were
even down
and that's so exciting it's not a
compromise it's a union of ideals that's
even makes a better ideal and then you
get to come home and then then there's
another rule that goes along with that
which is
please dear have the grace
to allow me to do this stupidly and
badly well i learned at least 20 times
yeah
and all give you the same leeway and
then we'll practice stupidly for 20
times and we'll talk about it and then
maybe we'll get it right for the next 10
000 times yeah right
and you can do that with your whole you
can do that with your whole life and you
can do that with your kids and you can
do that with your family like it's not
easy but you can do it's a lot easier
than the alternative
you